maybe tonight
get ready headless Toronto
[Music]
as somebody who is queer how does Billy
navigate the dating world the hookup
world are you on Grindr are you a
headless torso do you put your face up I
am a headless torso on grinder yes I'm
hoping to win the Tiff headless torso
award yeah I do everything that everyone
else does which is how I knew how to
write about it what are you into one of
these ripped idiots with no opinions no
I'd like someone who's physically very
frail and won't stop talking a lot of
it's coming from personal experience or
the experiences of my close gay friends
and I who share everything with each
other and have for years but yeah no I'm
in the thick of it yeah so when you send
a face pic to somebody you're like yeah
you're fake block sometimes yeah yeah so
sometimes they're like wait are you and
I'm like yeah and they're like how do I
know and I'm like I mean I don't know
how to prove it to you it really has
been blocked twice I've been blocked
twice on Tinder because people report my
account thinking it's fake and then I
went on Jimmy Kimmel and complained
about it and then Tinder saw it and felt
bad and sent me a care package and the
care package had a t-shirt that was like
world's greatest single and I was like
you're not helping this is making me
feel much worse and your chemistry
together in this film I'm watching these
intimate scenes between the two of you
and I'm like whoa chemistry is always
one of those things do you do you not
have and we did very early on we didn't
know each other before we got to know
each other on set which is a really
great thing to do and I think we're both
really curious about each other's lives
which is so much of what gay dating or
dating in general is about getting to
know somebody and we really got to do
that on camera
foreign
ER born with great taste
[Music]